honestly thank you on behalf of all of  the people of the state the family of  New York we talked about that we're a  family upstate downstate we're all one  family and that family is there to  support one another and I want to say  thank you on that behalf but I also want  to say you say thank you personally I  also want to say thank you on a personal  level because this hasn't been easy for  anyone but I want the the team here and  the people at pathways to know that they  gave me an inspiration and they gave me  energy and then they gave me resolve  their gesture was so beautiful and so  kind and so symbolic of everything we  want to be at our best everything we  aspire to be  everything we're all trying to be listen  to our better angels be better be more  generous more gracious more loving get  to that level that's what pathways did  and they did it for me and I wanted to  say thank you very much thank you god  bless you